INTERESTING. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY WILL
BEGIN. WE'RE GOING TO START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. I DO WANT TO MAKE
A COUPLE ANNOUNCEMENTS. WE HAVE
TEN BILLS ON THE CALENDAR. AB
2021 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER-KAHAN AND AB 2215 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN IS BEING
PULLED FROM TODAY'S CALENDARS BY
THE AUTHOR ITEM ONE, TWO, THREE,
SIX, EIGHT, NINE AND TEN ARE ON
CONSENT, SO THAT LEAVES ONE BILL
FOR US TO HEAR, I WILL, SINCE
WE'RE GOING TO ACTUALLY MOST
LIKELY HAVE QUORUM. CAN WE ASK
FOR QUORUM AND A ROLL CALL VOTE?
WAHAB HERE. WAHAB. HERE. SATO.
SATO. HERE. BRADFORD SKINNER
HERE. SKINNER. HERE. WIENER. ALL
RIGHT, WE DO HAVE QUORUM. WE'RE
GOING TO START. I'M JUST GOING
TO START WITH THIS, CAN I GET A
MOTION FOR CONSENT? SO MOTION
MOVED BY SENATOR SATO, CAN WE
GET A ROLL CALL? VOTE. WAHAB.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. SATO AYE. SATO.
AYE. BRADFORD. SKINNER. SKINNER
AYE. WIENER. ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILL IS ON Þ. THOSE BILLS ARE ON
CALL OR CONSENTS ON CALL. I
SHOULD SAY, AND THEN WE HAVE ONE
PRESENTATION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RENDON, LET ME FIND THE NUMBER
REAL QUICK. 2546 AB 2546
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YOU WOULD BE
PRESENTING RIGHT THERE. AND THEN
YOUR WITNESSES WILL BE
PRESENTING AT THIS MIC RIGHT
HERE. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I'D LIKE
TO START BY THANKING YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THE SUBJECT MATTER OF THIS
BILL. THIS BILL, AB 2546,
BROADENS THE DEFINITION OF
MILITARY WEAPON FOR THE PURPOSES
OF STATE LAW THAT GOVERNS HOW
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ACQUIRE
SUCH WEAPONS. BY BROADENING THE
DEFINITION, THIS BILL ENSURES
ALL MILITARY WEAPONS ARE
SUBJECTED TO THE SAME
TRANSPARENT PROCESSES DURING
ACQUISITION. JOINING ME TODAY IS
OBED FRANCO ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL'S SPONSORS, THE GENESIS
CORPORATION, THE MAKERS OF THE
LRAD. THANK YOU, GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
OBED FRANCO AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE GENESIS
CORPORATION. I'D LIKE TO START
ALSO BY THANKING YOU ALL IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL YOUR
WORK ON THIS ISSUE. AND I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK SPEAKER
EMERITUS RENDON FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
GENESIS IS IN FULL SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL 2546 AND IS
THANKFUL FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU. THAT WAS THE SHORTEST
SPEECH I'VE HEARD. DO YOU HAVE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES? THERE'S NO
OTHER WITNESSES. OKAY. DO WE
HAVE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE. DO WE HAVE ANY
METOOS IN EITHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL MOVE IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE MEMBERS, DO
YOU GUYS HAVE ANY COMMENTS?
SENATOR, MOVE THE BILL, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU, CAN WE GET A
ROLL CALL? VOTE AB 2546. RENDON.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO THE
FLOOR. WAHAB AYE. AYE. SATO.
SATO. NO. BRADFORD SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. WIENER. ALL RIGHT.
THAT BILLS ON CALL. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU GUYS. YEAH
THANK YOU. OH, THAT WAS THE
WIENER.
CAN WE LIFT THE CALL? ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CURRENT LEE,
IT'S 3 TO 0. WIENER. Ã. WIENER.
AYE ZERO CONSENT CALENDAR 4 TO 0
4 TO 0. THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
OUT. AB 2546. RENDON. Dð PASS TO
THE FLOOR. CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO
1. WIENER. Ã. WIENER. AYE THAT
BILL IS OUT. 3 TO 1, 3 TO 1. AND
NOW WE'RE DONE. ALL RIGHT. WE
ARE ADJOURNED. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU.